si on veut manger local pendant la
saison froide
ça veut dire qu'on mangera probablement
des légumes racines des pommes de terre
des neuf et des carottes mais de plus en
plus la verdure s'invite dans les
paniers du verre de certains producteurs
maraîchers bio et vous allez le voir ce
qu'ils arrivent à faire pousser en hiver
pratiquement sans chauffage est assez
impressionnant
à beuvry industrie nous sommes le 15
mars c'est une journée de fin d'hiver à
-15 degrés
dans la serre ont rempli les paniers de
plantes potagères produite sans
chauffage le dauphin 15 à 20 degrés à
l'intérieur voilà que le soleil sort
qu'on soit en janvier février mars la
température augmente dans la salle donc
c'est vraiment agréable d'aller
travailler dans les serres
c'est une pratique inhabituelle nos
productions maraîchères une culture
hivernale en pleine terre réalisé dans
une serre presque pas chauffer
on chauffe la nuit à 2,3 degrés mais
dans le jour ça chaufferait tu m'as
jamais le maraîcher frédéric verville et
sa compagne marie line wallet produisait
et livrer des paniers de légumes
biologiques mais ali vers 2021 le couple
s'est lancé dans la culture hivernale
les paniers de légumes racines sont
vendus embellie de fines herbes et
verdure est générale au panier c'est une
dizaine de légumes différents puis ces
deux à trois qui sont des vertus qui
sortent des soeurs le
[Musique]
maraîchage hivernale a ses limites
par exemple les tomates poivrons sont
exclus on m'a dit que ceux qui sont
résistantes au froid on les chauffe pour
s'assurer de la qualité pour s'assurer
d'une croissance mais c'est tout des
légumes qui sont quand même capable de
tolérer le froid
l'épinard est le roi de l'hiver avec un
potentiel de quatre récoltes d'autres
cultures sont aussi des succès les
oignons verts les verdures est et les
fines herbes comme la coriandre c'est
vraiment très productif puis assez
rentable aussi donc ce qu'on pense comme
celle ci c'est bien il ya surtout
d'avoir la coriandre qui est souvent
associé à à l'estival qu'on peut avoir
de la fraîcheur comme seul hiver
la quarantaine de maraîchers québécois
en régie biologique qui expérimente la
culture un climat frais s'inspire de
l'influente américain elliott coleman du
maine et
leur grand défi est d'ajuster la
pratique à nos températures
on essaie de choisir des cultures qu'on
est capable de faire plusieurs récoltes
parce que soit ce qui est lancée se
rendent à la première école puis ensuite
la deuxième récolte bien plus rapidement
pour cette première année une vingtaine
de variétés sont à l'essai dont le
onsite haye le yom qui se passe et la
tige [ __ ] un mélange de goûts environ
que les asperges et le brocoli puis
évidemment avoir un côté aussi les
feuilles après qu'on va faire des quais
auto puis en garde les fleurs pour la
fin pour mettre sur le dessus de nos
pizzas de nos par des risottos donc en
plus c'est très joli puis ça sent
vraiment bon sous un climat froid la
croissance est ralentie
les sucres sont concentrées évidemment
un goûteux sellerie était vraiment la
culture
étoiles de l'hiver sellerie qu'il a bien
failli perdre le contrôle de la serre le
contr'le chauffage au bois guy durand
une soirée en fait puis cache une
chauffer ma fournaise à 8 heures le soir
je me suis rendu compte que le chauffage
fonctionnait pas donc les céleris ici
toute la sert en fait à descendu à moins
huit degrés puis les céleris les tiges
sellerie était vraiment gelée de bar en
bar puis le seul problème qui a eu en
fait comme on peut voir c'est
principalement la marche des feuilles
qui ajuste ses chais qui est jonnie mais
tous les légumes dans la serre ont quand
même malgré tout survécu à la
température de - 8 pendant quelques
heures
[Musique]
pour chauffer les serres la nuit
frédéric utilise une fournaise à bois
déjà installés pour la maison le bois le
feu ça va chauffer de l'eau la fournaise
est entourée d'eau puis l'eau circule
dans les tuyaux jusqu'au sert en fait
par les tubes qui sont ici en terre
la chaleur est dissipée dans les serres
par des radiateurs et des ventilateurs
cette fournaise à peut fournir 500
milles bt eu pendant huit heures
le système chauffe la maison les serres
et l'atelier de travail le bois est un
combustible le plus économique que le
propane mais l'achat et l'installation
ne sont pas bon marché
c'est un système que coûte et grosso
modo ça m'aidera à usage c'est beaucoup
moins écouter ça qu on estime peut-être
trois fois moins cher qu elle propose
donc c'est un système qu en fait plus on
utilise plus rentables récolter de beaux
et bons légumes à feuilles en hiver
c'est faisable mais chacun fait ses
expériences
[Musique]
un des premiers projets de recherche sur
les cultures hivernales et mené au cégep
de victoriaville par le centre
d'expertisé et de transfert en
agriculture biologique et de proximité
le cetab le ministère de l'agriculture
du québec finance la recherche juste en
soit la culture de climat fraysse c'est
un contexte qu'on connaît quand même
très peu au niveau de la régie culture
juste le comportement des cultures aussi
avec la baisse de luminosité puis
ensuite le retour de la luminosité
progressif ya quand même un effet sur
les cultures qui est peu reconnu
ici à victoriaville on récolte les
données dans trois types de structures
utilisées par les producteurs des mini
tunnel une serre chauffée à 5 degrés est
cet autre sert non chauffés ou la nuit
il fait froid comme à l'extérieur
au coucher du soleil la protection des
plantes est essentielle on en est une de
jusqu'à même trois épaisseurs des paies
pour vraiment venir réchauffer au niveau
du seul alors que le reste du volume
d'air de là ça va être à moins 10 -15
degrés celsius le
le prolongement de la saison est évaluée
aussi dans cinq fermes de régions
différentes
premier constat l'impact de la date des
semis sur le rendement peut varier du
simple au double si on prend une épine
or par exemple qui serait implanté une
date normale au 14 septembre on parle
d'une cinquantaine de jours à maturité
fission on parle maintenant d'une date
de semis fin octobre dans une star non
chauffés on est plutôt à
130 jours
côté rentabilité les cultures établi au
bon moment sont toutes là différentes on
a déjà eu le temps entre septembre et
aujourd'hui de faire plusieurs récoltes
l'otan dans les quatre cultures leurs
quêtes et pinard voc treuil salanova
pour la requête du premier signe par
exemple on est déjà rendu à la troisième
coupe en estrie l'agronome geneviève
legault accompagne des producteurs
maraîchers qui tentent l'expérience
hivernale à des températures de 5 degrés
c'est vraiment un autre monde fait il ya
très peu de recherches sur ces contextes
présentement même s'il est hivernale ce
maraîchage n'est pas à l'abri des
ravageurs on a des insectes et des
maladies dans les serres d'été et puis
qui peuvent passer l'automne et l'hiver
dans les serres ses sorties à
l'extérieur l'hiver il ya pas beaucoup
d'insectes donc c'est vraiment des
essais qui proviennent qui ont hiberné
le sur les cultures
par exemple cette chenille unodc thuel
fiancée découverte sur place par
l'agronome
sever grid a été très présent dans les
champs au cours de l'été
et en hiver les prédateurs ne sont pas
d'un grand secours pour éliminer les
ravageurs la plupart des prédateurs sont
censés bas la photopériode vont rentrer
en dormance en moins actifs ont moins
consommé un grand intérêt motive les
producteurs maraîchers de paniers
biologiques à prolonger leur saison sous
des abris peu ou pas chauffée je pense
que ça va se jouer avec la rentabilité
quand les producteurs vont vraiment bien
maîtrisé le côté technique on est en
mesure de comprendre c'est quoi les
rendement maximum qu'on peut atteindre
jusqu ici chauffer au propane lasserre
expérimental à 5° coûte 10 $ par jour on
prévoit jusqu'à 20 dollars par grand
froid
chauffée à zéro degré 2° ou 5 degrés
cela recherche qui permettra bientôt de
connaître le mode idéal
c'est quand même dommage que dans les
épiceries la majorité des verdures
l'hiver proviennent de californie aps
avec l'augmentation dessert aussi au
québec on a des espaces à occuper on à
l'espace pour les produire
premier descendre le couple verville
ouellette entame sa deuxième saison
hivernale avec enthousiasme c'est au nom
de la rocade puis dur a fini au choix
avec du caillou si ils ont cessé la
livraison en est et de légumes frais une
cultivant chaud que des légumes de
conservation pour l'hiver une économie
d'argent en main d'oeuvre et tout
changement de vie mais clairement ça a
été vraiment plus tranquille on ne put
prendre des vacances dans la famille
pendant plus d'une semaine puis beaucoup
moins stressant je suis moins grognon
[Musique]